so i came on the show to talk about only
two things and one of them is how
is my investment strategy where after 20
years of of making like
i don't know like 60 investments i've
now figured out exactly how to do what
you're just what you're talking about
you want to hear the breakdown
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on
the road let's
travel never look sean all right we're
live what's going on um
i did something last night i had dinner
with uh
andrew hey hi becca and uh so
the bat i gotta tell people the
background of the story because it's fun
uh basically shawn tweeted this thing
got viewed by like
probably six million people at the time
he politely
but he still said it that he thinks
clubhouse is gonna like die
it was polite whatever andrew chen
who's a a friend of mine is
basically discovered clubhouse i think
he was their first investor he loves the
company he thinks it's gonna be the
biggest thing ever
invested in um blocked sean
invested in it black sean and uh sean po
this sounds like silly drama and it is
but it's fun but but it's fun
uh sean blocked i didn't block him or
sean got blocked
and he sean you posted a a picture of it
and that alone got thousands and
thousands of likes
so anyway i just think it's fun i'm a
little caught in the middle
so it sucks for me i'm not def i'm not
actually defending i'm i'm actually
defending both sides
but i'm not i'm uh i'm staying neutral
but i i think both
both parties are actually right so did
he block me because i think it's fine
at me or why did he block me
he just says that he goes i have a rule
that i just don't like
a lot of negativity on my twitter feed
and also anyone that disrespects anyone
that i'm associated with i just
automatically block i don't even reply
which i think is fair i actually think
that's a good i'm on board with that
i don't think you're disrespectful but i
i it's cool that he feels that way uh
yeah that's okay i i think it's fine um
i was surprised because i met andrew
before and we were friendly
um like you know before this i would
have thought
andrew is somebody who um you know if i
see something interesting i would send
it to him i'd be like hey this i think
this is right up your alley and he'd be
like cool thanks man and
you know we if we saw each other at a at
a meet-up or a party we would say hello
like you know it was
it was like that so i was surprised when
he blocked me him and mark andreessen
blocked me so
uh both of them you know followed before
and then went straight to block without
like
you know anything in between i i'm cool
with that
i'm sure you guys will all be i'm sure
you'll all be friends eventually you
guys are all
great i totally get it you know like if
i respect them if i think someone's just
being a hater or
like you know and for them i think they
get it from all angles like
they're always fighting with what's her
name taylor lorenz and like you know
different people in the media and [__]
like that
or they're probably just like dude i
just like they're probably just tired of
people who are
critics uh or critical and i think
there's a difference right there's one
person who's a critic and this is
somebody who sits on the sideline
and they're a professional criticizer um
and i think there's a difference between
being critical which is to say
hey actually like i'm trying to uh i've
noticed some things or i've made some
observations
and here's my opinion and i don't know
if i'm right or wrong i'm saying it as
an opinion clearly
and secondly i hope this is not true i
hope they succeed and i was genuine
about that that wasn't like
just some [__] i put in there um and
i'm clearly somebody who has
been through it i'm not just like
somebody on the sideline throwing rocks
you know like there's that thing that
that quote uh that everybody loves
that's like you know some teddy
roosevelt quote or whatever the man in
the arena
you know it's not the critic who counts
type of thing and i would say in this
case
you know i'm neither the man in the
arena because i'm not doing this startup
um nor am i the critic who just sits in
the bleachers
and you know boos you know i'm like the
man who was in the arena got my ass
kicked by the same competitor
and i'm trying to yell to the man in the
arena hey watch out
this you know this this competitor is no
joke and um here's why here's something
if you try this move this might be a
problem if you try this move this might
be a problem
i hope you don't try those too the issue
the issue is is that your thing
you're polite but criticism nonetheless
reached so many people
that it it you could actually
impact the outcome i i i people might
think i'm crazy i think that i think
that tweet
could potentially uh uh have a
have a say i think this will have zero
impact on the company uh in terms of
that if anything it should have a
positive impact or maybe the
product people inside the company read
it and they say okay you know what are
the
if you take the jokes and the zingers
out and you just look at the actual like
like the kind of the product
observations what the challenges might
be
cool like do we think we have a good uh
do we think this is true and if we do
think it's true do we have any good um
counter attacks for what this problem
might be and how we might actually solve
this problem
um i think that would be the positive
somebody people keep sending me these
charts because the google trends in the
app store
keeps showing that clubhouse going down
like sharply like recently
and they're like oh the sean pury effect
i'm like no no there's
zero percent chance i could do that and
if anything
most people haven't even heard of
clubhouse yet i haven't had access to it
so if anything
a bunch of drama about clubhouse should
actually be driving interest up
in checking it out or googling it and
trying to figure out what this what is
the fuss about
uh if anything but you know the other
thing is i get there
what the thing that might have pissed
them off is like okay the tweet storm
was a little over the top
you know maybe unnecessary but uh
okay you know forgivable uh but then you
know the next day i go on cnbc
and do a two-minute segment about it and
they're at that point you're just like
who is this [__] guy and why is he on
this crusade against clubhouse why is he
going on tv talking [__]
and like my only response to that is uh
hey if i get invited on the cnbc i'm
just going to say yes
like i know that sounds a little silly
or selfish but like
i don't know put yourself in my shoes
would you not want the opportunity to go
on tv like
i think that's fine and i don't think i
said anything that was
harsh or untrue to them so you know
anyways i i could see them being annoyed
i just got off the phone
i just got off the phone with hubspot's
pr people because we were talking about
something and
i was like you guys see shawn on a
squawk box or whatever it's called
and they were like yeah they're like he
killed it and i'm like yeah it's
it it made me happy that these like
uptight they're not uptight but i
i i pegged them in my head yeah i
pegged them in my head as being such
that uh they've been on board with you
like you didn't do anything wrong but
like you've made funny con you're
talking about kim kardashian's butt and
they were like it was awesome
so i'm happy they're on board uh so in
this episode we're gonna talk about
big clout right but before we do that we
have ryan beagleman he's on the line
he's going to come on in a second
before we do that i wanted to bring up
two things with you the first thing
do you remember a couple months ago when
we talked about a carbon offset
credit card so i have to learn exactly
how this works but we discussed this of
about this idea of basically taking a
mastercard and just putting slightly
different branding and slightly
different perks and building a business
a company that we uh didn't know existed
just raised
250 million dollars today building an
uh a carbon offset credit card called
aspiration i think it's called
no see that see that uh aspiration is
the name
yeah i just linked to it in our thing
it's called the la's socially conscious
bank challenger aspiration
launches a carbon offset credit card
they raise 250 million dollars from
leonardo dicaprio
orlando bloom but then they have some
like actual real people like alan and co
uh cool we we we uh
we called that one yeah there's actually
i can't oh wait a minute had they
already raised i think they had already
raised 100 million as well
right did we miss that ten months months
ago
we uh our ignorance of not knowing about
them also still shows that we predicted
it even if it
had already happened um i actually am
investing in another one i'll send it to
you it's stealthy right now but when we
can talk about it we'll talk about it
the founder
started a media company actually before
this uh
grew it huge sold it coming back to
market with a credit similar
similar idea a credit card where the
rewards the perks
and the branding are around a different
part of your lifestyle and not
like you know the generic which is like
cash back or travel rewards travel
points you know go stay in a marriott
for a fourth night free
um and like what these carbon guys are
doing what from what it sounds like is
that
for somebody who is eco-conscious you
know specifically eco-conscious they
would rather
make their impact and have the rewards
be something that is helping the
environment then get that fourth night
at the marriott
and the this guy that i'm investing in
um he's got a different one
do i know i don't know if you know him
personally but you know of the thing
that they built before this and so
you'll you'll like it so
uh it's a very similar idea can i
send it to you and we can we can do it
and then we can talk about it when he
launches it i'm in
let's just do that love i'll bring to
you the stuff
which i brought i showed you two cameras
are you gonna join
i'll we'll show each other stuff and
then let's just talk about it on here
because i think people like that so far
every time we've talked about investing
people have liked it because you get to
hear about a new concept
we're not just saying oh that's neat
we're saying like no i put money into
this that's a certain level of
conviction and skin in the game
and then um also there's like the people
who are interested on the investing side
which is like
cool so like how do you how do you
invest what do you decide on what are
the check sizes what
what type of returns do you expect what
type of returns do you end up getting
what were your big mistakes
people like that type of [__] uh and
i'll say i guess i can say no i put 10
grand
into toucan and then we did a syndicate
where we put in 150
total which i kind of shocked me i
thought it was going to be like 50 000.
um but i did 10 on that one of my own
money yeah that's cool
yeah i think that's interesting one also
deciding what's your what's your basic
check gonna be like
i um like you decided 10k the first
few angel investments i did were
basically i think 25k
and then i like randomly did like a 50k
one and then i just felt like oh [__] i
like
you know that 50k felt like a
significant like
a more significant bet than the 25k ones
did to me the psychologically
and so then there's like there's a math
behind how do you want your portfolio
structure and all that [__] and then
there's the psychology around
you want to bet an amount of you want to
be bidding an amount of money that will
matter to you where you care and you'll
track it and you'll do the work
so not too little but also not too much
where you become emotionally wrapped up
in the outcome which you cannot control
and
is you know subject to all these
different variables anyways
i was going to do and actually we could
bring ryan on yeah ryan
cameron because he was telling me about
his he was telling me about
his buddy who i don't know if he wants
to say his name about what his process
was
and and we could talk about in a second
but we're going to talk about the guy
who hired an analyst ryan but
uh my um my uh philosophy right now with
angel investing is
i was gonna do uh maybe a quarter of a
million to
three hundred thousand dollars in the
next 12 months
and i was gonna do it in increments of
ten to fifteen thousand dollars gotcha
my
oh my quick reaction to that is that
that's too many deals a too small of an
amount you know you'd rather do i think
because because just to do that like
okay let's just do the math real quick
so that means you're basically saying
yes to 30 deals
to say yes to 30 deals let's you know
about how many deals do you think you'll
need to
what percent hit rate do you have or
acceptance rate so from a deal you see
you either look at a pitch deck you meet
a founder uh you take a meeting
to saying yes you don't want that to be
like a hundred percent you don't want it
to even be 50
probably what do you think just for you
just off top your head spitballing
what percent of your deals do you think
you'll say yes to or do you want to be
saying yes to
30 okay that's a i think that's still
probably fairly high but okay let's say
the phone off the phone call right okay
so of all phone calls people who make it
to the phone call you want to do 30.
right
so let's just let's just totally no i'm
not saying
i'm not saying i want to do i'm saying
that yeah but i also think i say no to
most everything that i'm emailing okay
so let's say let's just take the
meetings part okay
so that means you know for for doing 30
deals you're going to need to take
you're going to need 90 at least of
those one hour meetings
um to to get to that hit rate and
so 91 hour meetings that's 90 hours of
like
kind of like founder meetings and so it
just ends up being a lot and then now
you have 30 deals to like add value to
to help to make intros for to do all
those things so it ends up being
a lot of maintenance and a lot of
vetting for very small ownership and
uh small checks but it is a good way to
just see a bunch of [__] so
i like the strategy from that point of
view what do you think ryan
so i came on the show to talk about only
two things and one of them is how
is my investment strategy where after 20
years of of making like
i don't know like 60 investments i've
now figured out exactly how to do what
you're just what you're talking about
you want to hear the breakdown well can
you first tell me the story
can you tell the story of of the person
you know who what what they did
well let me i can i explain this theory
and then i'll tell and i'll tell you how
that plugs into it
yeah so i think that the the filter for
me is
actually turned into i think there's an
icky guy for investing
so you know there's the icky guy concept
i know you guys are both familiar with
you know you choose your career based on
what you love to do
what you're good at doing or what
there's a market need for right and at
the intersection of those three things
is like exactly the thing that you will
you'll be best at and enjoy
well my epiphany looking back on my like
60 or some odd like angel and real
estate investments is that
the ones that generally perform well are
the ones that are
at the intersection of what i'm
naturally curious about
where i'm well networked and where
there's good fundamentals
so it's a similar like icky guy right
concept where
and so my main my main filter for
for making investments now is is this
something i'm
actually sincerely fascinated by i'm
regularly reading about
and i'm well networked in like so for
example like
i made some investments like you know in
healthcare
which i don't know [__] about i'm not
well networked in and
yeah the fundamentals are amazing like
healthcare is only growing in america if
you
know costs are rising whatever like but
those have not been predictably
looking back like those have not been as
good as say
my investments in coinbase warby parker
like uber
and like real estate investments where i
was well networked i was really
interested for a long time
and the fundamentals were good so what
do you guys make of that
so i'm a framework guy i like anytime
somebody has a
framework or a thought process around
how they do what they do the only thing
i would say is that
for me whenever you see something
growing really fast and you see that the
fundamentals actually make sense
um it's very easy to get the other two
to work so for example
i can get really curious about something
when i see something working extremely
well
i'm like wow what the hell is this and
then i can curiosity can follow it
doesn't always have to lead for me
and the second thing is well networked
what i found is that like the whole kind
of like
value-add side of investing is sort of a
load of [__] um
you know i agree i don't whenever
whenever we raise money i was like i
don't want to talk to you ever again
unless you're just having fun with you
like we're just and that's hanging out
maybe i'm just bad at it but
what i see and i do the same thing by
the way when i talk to founders i'm like
look
here's what i've done in my life uh if
any of that applies to what you're doing
i've been through a bunch of [__]
i've done a lot of these steps that you
are about to do so i think i could
probably help
and secondly like i'm particularly good
at these three things and by the way
like i think your messaging
sucks and i think i'm good at messaging
you know yeah you know i think
i can do the the pitch better than you
your deck is a little bit weak
i can help you with your deck those are
true in reality the amount of times that
gets taken up and actually has some
material impact
it's just so low well i i i'm not saying
i'm using my network to help the
investments i agree i rare i rarely help
the people i invest with materially
i'm saying i got in early to say
because of my network yeah and i i can't
get in early like i tried getting an
early
you know to say like uh spacex
like i wasn't well networked then now i
became better networked
around spacex later and i ended up
investing later
but like there's certain areas where i
have an unfair advantage to getting
investments right and by the way we
should introduce you so ryan uh
you know you were part of summit you've
been on the pod before many times i
think
uh built a media company sold it was one
of the co-founders of summit summit
series
they bought them out and did crazy [__]
uh and i would say you know
one of the more well-liked guests on the
pod because
has real business knowledge and also
knows how to deliver it in a way that's
entertaining to people so a good sense
for
entertainment so uh excited to have you
on you have been infected by this mind
virus can we just talk about it or do we
need to like i feel like
talking about anything like a big cloud
cloud can't even enter my brain right
now
i honestly have canceled almost
everything on my calendar because
big cloud is so addictive and so much
fun
and so lucrative so far on paper that
i just can't i can't talk about anything
my wife wants to throw me out of the
house right now like
so the good news here guys is that i
signed up for big clout but i pretty
much
only signed up because ryan just called
me and said uh i want to talk to you
about this
sign up i i don't really know what it is
so you guys could talk about it and i'll
be the one asking the questions on
behalf of the audience
right like an idiot so let's take a stab
because it's kind of new
and foreign and most almost i would say
99 percent of the people listen to this
are not
active on bitcoin yet um let's each take
a stab at it ryan and see
if we can get to a simple explanation of
what the heck it is
so here's my here's my simple
explanation sam big clout is basically
like a stock market for people so me and
you and ryan and anybody else
uh we each have like a little coin a
price
where you could buy some of our stock
let's call it um
and so people are going on there and
they're using bitcoin to buy
our stock because they believe that
we're going to continue to get more
popular
and our reputations are going to grow
and that owning a piece
of our limited um coin uh the
you know if i own 10 of your your stock
basically
uh i feel good about that because i
think in the next 10 years you're going
to be
getting even more popular right so it's
a way to bet on people
and so that's the f which we which we've
talked about a lot we love this we've
we've looked at humanity
like what we talked about before which
is like is it for income sharing is it
for x
is it for y is it for z right now it's
literally for nothing and so the
reason this is cool right now is because
uh nobody knows who's behind it they're
kind of like
being stealthy about it people know but
nobody has publicly outed who's
who's behind it um i do know the name of
the
people behind it but i know people who
know the person people i trust
say they know who it is and they because
i asked they were like yo i'm buying
your coin are you gonna
are you gonna actually use big cloud or
not i was like well i don't know is this
like a scam it kind of looks scammy to
me
and they were like yeah i thought so too
because it's kind of the
the secretive way that they're going
about it but actually i know the
founders they're like legit people from
the tech scene they like kind of have a
reputation
in our circles um and a bunch of the big
name tier one vcs are involved in it
now that doesn't mean it's not going to
fail it doesn't mean it's not us
like maybe something unethical is going
to happen or that's going to get hacked
or
who knows any any number of bad things
can happen but it's not
random guy and you know not nigerian
prince is kind of the
the main thing that that i've heard now
you you guys
you're forgetting a major part here
which is if you go to big it's bit
clout c-l-o-u-t dot com
you can't actually do it you don't have
a password it's all
you need a password so you guys are
forgetting it's inviting only right now
and you have to have
this you know similar to clubhouse and
superhuman like you know this is
one of the techniques in silicon valley
now to build hype
and get early adopters to want to in is
to not let them in and then
make it so they can only get in if they
have the secret secret codes
so okay right that was my my attempt
what would you change about it how would
you describe it differently
yeah i know i think you nailed it i mean
it's a social currency platform
i think you put it more simply you can
bet on people so like take sam
so i called sam last night i'm like dude
what the heck are you doing how are you
not on big cloud yet
you need to get on here you need to
create your profile so he goes on he
creates his profile
i put in two thousand dollars into into
this at the same part on big cloud
i then you know i i then
watched it overnight and when i woke up
this morning i had already made like
five six thousand dollars what and so
yeah
so let's walk through me and sam's coins
so can you just pull up
actually the site's down which which is
sort of problematic
so that's a that's a bit of an issue
it'll come back up but it's getting
hammered with traffic i think
so last ice last you saw ryan what was
my
coin trading for and do you remember my
market cap
i don't i'd so it's so annoying in the
sights down because i was hoping to have
it ready
but i want to say you you were pretty
legit first off i just want to say like
you're you're
you're trading at a at a relatively high
number relative to like your fame and
like your twitter handle
you were which which i what i've noticed
is people who are known in the crypto
world
disproportionately are doing well on the
platform so like
like i bet yesterday on chuck norris and
i'm
because because part of my strategy is
to buy people who are
trading at a cheap number relative to
like the following they have on twitter
or instagram
and like [__] norris was trading at like
but you know he's got a huge like he's a
big following he's obviously pretty
famous even though he's like
you know a scene celebrity but
i don't get any of that money you do
so you can set whatever percentage you
want to take
of the of the coin that people invest in
so the default is 10
so if i buy like a thousand dollars
worth of sample
i believe the way the math works is uh
you'll take 10
of that in coin and so what's cool about
that is like as you become more famous
as you build up a reputation
and as you keep your reputation you know
good in the public eye
like in theory your big cloud uh market
cap will grow
and you'll take 10 of that now what i've
seen some people do
who have money like you sam is they they
they set their percentage down at zero
instead of 10 which is the default
because they don't want to discourage
people from buying their
their coin and then they just buy their
own coin
and then they bet on themselves which is
something oh my gosh
as okay i saw this a few days ago and i
saw
oh wow some people have bought like i
think somebody had bought ten thousand
dollars worth
my coin um and basically i was trading
for almost two thousand dollars per
coin and my my own holdings that they
kind of like
give you through your i don't know if
it's like a founder reward or like a
a ten percent vig you get on every buy
or something like that
my own holdings if i claimed my account
i had sixty thousand dollars worth of my
coin ready for me so the the
the genius of their model is this wait
you had six
months my own coin what i what they
basically what i had gotten from the the
way that the site works
if i if i verified my account so here's
how it works this is this is the genius
the growth hack that they have which is
very very smart and um so what they do
is they
pre-made all of our accounts they took
the top 15 000 twitter accounts i think
and they made profiles for all of them
they made coins for all of them
immediately
and then they let some people in with
bitcoin to go buy up whoever they wanted
so people start buying coins
and of course every time you buy a coin
the default is a ten percent
if i buy a hundred coins of yours ten of
those coins go to you
and 90 come to me so there's like a like
the brokerage fee
goes to the creator themselves so what
this did was you're elon musk you're
naval you're
you're you know on a smaller scale us um
and you you go on the site and right now
it basically says
cool if you log in and verify that you
are you you you
are sean vp on twitter you get to claim
your coins
uh your coins are sitting there in this
account so i have a 60 like
last time i checked this was a few days
ago but before several friends bought my
coin so i might have more now
but i had a 53 000 uh
bounty just waiting for me all i had to
do was connect it to my twitter account
and tweet out
hey i'm on bitcloud you know like uh
come buy my coin or whatever
if i did if i know i didn't do that
because at the time i didn't know
is this legit am i promoting a scam and
so i went did some background checks i
asked a few people who i knew were
buying my coin i said
what you know is this real or is this
not like ryan you know and others
and so um and so that's how simple it is
so so think about that mechanism
right now i have cornered the sandpark
market if you look at sampara i
are his biggest holder um and
and i plan to buy more sandpark as soon
as the site comes back
guys listen it wasn't like
it wasn't i can't tell you what's like
the red pill blue pill phrase
what's the what's the what's the pill
that you take what your perception is
completely changed
i can't go back okay maybe i'm just like
a blue pill guy here
but like it wasn't that long ago that i
was so
poor that i would put two pieces of
pizza into one whole foods box
and so i could just like only pay for
one or where i would like eat
half the food out of my container before
i weighed it
uh like it wasn't that long ago that i
was that poor where i
where i was stealing food from the
grocery store now
we're talking about sean just logging in
and being like oh
beep bop boop fifty thousand dollars in
my account yeah
does this stuff freak you out this kind
of freaks me out no it does not freak me
out at all i think it's awesome that i
could log in and get 50 000
i think that's cool now okay here's some
of the criticisms right uh and this is
where sam your [__] detector is
about to like
you know fly around the room you're
about to raise your eyebrows all the way
to the moon when you hear this which is
that
you could transfer money in and you
could buy coins but there's no
withdrawals right now
you cannot watch so i could go in and
verify i could claim my fifty thousand
dollars what i can't do is put that in
my bank account
um that's a feature that conveniently is
not available and not built yet now
they are going to do it um the the main
thing for them is that
um they say oh we're building it it's
not ready yet
in reality my theory is basically if you
allowed people to immediately come in
grab 100k grab 50. if i can come and
grab 50k
withdraw it out of the system it's going
to kind of crash the network
it's not going to like the whole system
kind of fails there's this
there's this theory about sort of um you
know like one of the reasons bitcoin is
so valuable is because the central
philosophy of the religious bitcoin
holders
is to hold the coin uh if you're selling
out of it the price drops
and so what they want right now is for
everybody to hold their hold coins
so that the network can get big enough
get enough strength and then
once it's bigger and more popular you
can add liquidity and people can trade
it and now and it won't
just completely crash the system so
do we just have so much money going
around right now that we have to invent
okay so here's okay so let me explain to
you because i also was like what the
hell is this
and then i was sent the one pager and i
want to actually read to you guys
the one pager pdf uh this might be a
little boring
a pdf but honestly when i read this so i
talked to ryan i don't know like
40 minutes ago on the phone before this
podcast i was like yo
okay we're coming on i'm excited about
big cloud i heard a little bit about it
but i haven't had time to look at it i
just had a kid
like i haven't had a chance to go in and
kick the tires and he was like dude
this is like the most you've ride you
said this right you're this is the most
addictive thing since
for early facebook for you craziest
thing i've i've been i'm like all my
friends have been up all night like
one one's in alaska heli skiing another
one is in utah like we're all
texting all night hey who's buying chuck
norris has anyone figured out like oh i
just 10xed on gwyneth paltrow
like a number a number of my friends
like guys who worked for me at summit
who have like maybe 50 000 saved have
put in like a quarter of their net worth
and in the last like four or five days
of five to 10x their money right
like but they can't get anything out
they can't get enough they get it out
yet but i
i contacted the founder of a pretty
major um like crypto hedge fund and he
assured me that
they bet quite a lot on this and that
he's confident that they will there will
be a way out plus the founder also said
that
eventually there'll be an exchange you
know where you could sell it
um it's just the easiest thing i've seen
let me give you both how do i make
sampar the game style yeah
well first of all calling it game stock
is perfect that's all right you're
already memeing yourself
stop yeah whatever so okay so here's the
okay
because when we were talking on the
phone ryan i was like so you're buying
my coin
great what what's the reason why would
you want my coin what does that do for
you
like i get that if i get more popular in
theory my coin could get more popular
but that assumes more people will want
to buy it
why would they want to buy it what are
they getting out of this it's like well
then they
think you're going to get even more
popular then the next person will want
to buy it right so there is definitely
like a greater full theory
that underlies this whole thing which is
that i'm buying it today because i think
somebody else is going to come buy this
tomorrow
either because the creator i'm buying is
going to get more popular
or big cloud is going to get more
popular in reality right now
both are going to happen and um and so
so i think it's actually a
good bet even if you know going in that
this is
greater fool theory this is uh i'm i'm
looking to pass this to the next guy and
make
a lot of money before the music stops so
i think that's the skeptical way of
looking at it
now let me tell you the like why this
actually might be a thing long term
and i'm going to read to you from the
pdf um
what they say this is okay so sam i'm
gonna read read this to you and you just
tell me paragraph by paragraph
is your belief going up or down okay
um where did you find this i just
googled bit
bit cloud yeah i'll send it to you it's
a white paper
where are you guys getting this bro
we're connected on the inside not
connected enough to know who's actually
doing this but connected enough to know
the people who know the people
um all right so big cloud is a new type
of social network that lets you
speculate on people
and their posts with real money as built
on a blockchain okay cool then it goes
uh it's a fully open source project um
there's no company behind it just coins
and code
so then it says um let me skip to the
part about creator coins
what are creator coins everyone has a
coin every profile on the platform gets
its own coin that you can buy and sell
these are crater coins uh you get one
you get you can have your own
crater coins just by creating a profile
and they already pre-created a whole
bunch of profiles
because you know i didn't do it but my
my creative coin exists
okay then i had to make mine then it
says
you can buy your favorite person's coin
to buy someone else's to buy someone's
coin you just go to their profile you
click buy
for the top 15 000 influencers on
twitter it's preloaded into the platform
um okay cool so now uh then it says
tweet to claim your profile the owner of
a profile
can claim their profile by tweeting out
their public key
this will give them full access to their
account as well as the percentage of
their founder rewards which is
that's what i was talking about my 50k
that's sitting there for me that's my
founder reward for claiming my account
now the genius of it is
by me tweeting out like i have a big
incentive to tweet this out right
because
i get access to my fifty thousand
dollars so they're basically kind of
like paying me fifty thousand dollars
to tweet out about big cloud and if
enough of the and the bigger you are the
bigger your reward
and so they're gonna get a lot of big
people to tweet this thing out which is
going to create this like enormous
hype cycle okay so then it says what are
creator coins useful for so this is
where it starts to become interesting it
goes
there's a new asset class that's tied to
the reputation of an individual
for example let's say elon musk succeeds
in being the first person to land
uh land on mars put a person to mars his
coin price should theoretically go up
because he will be world renowned for it
um and if in contrast he makes a racial
slur during a press conference his coin
price should go down because his
reputation takes a hit his popularity
uh goes down so you as a trader can make
money by buying and selling the ups and
downs of
speculating on a person's future
popularity okay so then it says
state what could you use the coins for
um so today it's just about buy and sell
but in the future
let's say that you know right now for
example i think craig clemens is my
biggest coin holder he has like i don't
know ten fifteen thousand dollars in my
coin
ryan's gotta run how much of my coin you
got what
um i think i bought like three four
thousand dollars so
what can i do to reward the people who
own my coins so that more people want to
buy my coins so one is a stakeholder
meeting
so you can basically say okay i'm gonna
do an ama or a q a for anybody who owns
over
you know 100 of my coins at whatever
so what do you tell them like hey
everyone i wanted to give you an update
on the next quarter
i'm thinking that i'm not going to say
anything just exactly racist
but i am going to do that i am going to
film someone committing suicide which
might make me think you're not going to
totally about your own popularity you're
saying
okay for my super fans who want access
to me you want more access like let's
say
you know like for example our friend
andrew wilkinson has
done a thing where he says cool buy this
expensive thing for charity
and you get to do a lunch with me or you
get to join this ama's q a
exclusively with me and 25 people who
pay the five grand to this all the
proceeds go to charity
it's that same idea if people want to do
a want to ask you a question or whatever
so here's a simpler version right that's
like
you get to attend a private meeting for
people who own
x amount of my coin the other way is to
say look i get a bunch of spam in my
inbox every day people email me people
dm me and literally this is true there's
so many of those and i don't respond to
of them and unfortunately some of the
good ones just get mixed up in
all the random junk that people send me
so here's the thing i have an inbox the
inbox is a
has a contract that basically says
anybody who um
if you want to message me it costs you
five coins um and my coin has a real
price so you you can do that by either
having a huge amount of my coin or going
and buying some in order to message me
and i will respond to everybody who rep
who sends me this paid message
through this channel right so now i can
have an inbox that has a price with it
or i can prioritize it based on sort
this by my biggest coin holders because
those are my vips i want to talk to them
first i want to give them replies first
another another idea they have uh
sponsored posts
so i can have an inbox that basically
says you can pay
me you can you can buy a certain amount
of my coin and i'll retweet your thing
um and so it's just a simple like you
don't need an
essential middleman agency to set up
like these paid promotion deals it's
just i just set a price
or people just bid a price and i just
look at it and i say okay i'll take 100
coins 100 of my own coin
for posting this thing i don't mind i
actually like the thing you told me to
post
and then the last one like there's an
only fans version of this where
cool if you have this man if you pay
this much coin of my coin per month you
get exclusive content
the last one is what they call money
likes so let's say
uh like let's reimagine the like button
so instead of just being able to smash
like on everything
let's say that it costs a tiny amount of
coin to like something so
for me putting out a good post like
let's say that clubhouse thing i did
that went viral
today all i got was fame i didn't make
any money off the fact that seven
million people saw that thing twitter
made money but i didn't make any money
so in this case if i put out great
content that goes viral like my my
clubhouse thing
then every person who's hitting the like
could be basically
buying in order like they're buying a
micro amount of my own coin
and so i earn for posting good content
um in that way
and by the by that person buying my coin
by hitting like
they're actually sort of investing in in
me right because they hit the like let's
say it cost one sean coin to do it they
bought one sean coin
they hit the like button because they
like my content now let's say i keep
getting more popular they still own that
coin so our both of us have an incentive
to do that
those are some of the ideas what do you
think
where i am right now is like it's
there's one of three things happening
one either my iq is just low enough that
i can't keep up with you guys when you
discuss this
two um i'm just out of touch and like
it's happening where like
when my wife started getting a job at
facebook her dad was like why do you
need it why do they need all these
people it's just a web
it's just a website like am i am i
getting
am i getting out of touch or three um
this is [__] and i'm right well can
i can i give you a simpler use case
so right now i'm uh you know i've been
doing executive coaching i think as you
guys know and i've been
i'm coaching the the founder and ceo of
morning brew and i think
we should pick austin reef and
alex lieberman a morning brew against
the sam
at the sam par on big cloud i'm i'm
going to
buy coin in all of them and let's see
who can become
the bigger market cap in the next 30
days
but i don't want to do that like i'd
wouldn't it be better if i just spent
time in like making money on [__] that i
own
in the entirety of but these this is
like i thought these guys are like like
your nemesis this is a newsletter war
between the hustle and the morning the
final i've cashed out dude i've won
like i like
like i i have everything i need i've
i've i have
i've won my game as far as i can tell
austin is crushing you on big clown in
terms of his market gap right there
there you go
now those competitive juices are
starting to flow he's like i don't care
but if you're saying he's crushing me at
a game i don't care about
i start to care about the game a little
bit no i have the game i care about
is my bank account and what time i could
wake up in the morning that's the rest
of my days
your popul no that's not my big account
what how many houses you'll be able to
scenario one these guys never build a
way to cash out this whole thing is a
scam
all the smart people that are involved
in it are wrong cool there is a
percentage chance that that is true
i don't know what that percentage is
might be one percent might be 50 let's
just take that off the table because if
that's true then yeah there's no
discussion it's stupid
and useless if if you're buying if you
can only buy in but never sell out like
you know what what is this you know
robin hood like you can't you can't do
that so
here's the the other side of it let's
say it is liquid
where you can trade some of your coins
for actual cash if you want it
or bitcoin if you want it um but people
are going to be betting on hey
this podcast going to keep getting more
popular sam's going to keep getting more
popular he's going to keep doing more
things i've seen his twitter account
growing
he posts awesome content i want to get
on on the ground ground floor of sam
and they start buying your coin because
they want to hold a piece of
the sampar popularity like clout score
basically
and they're they believe more people are
gonna buy it so now more people do start
buying it
and um your stock goes up your stock
goes up because you sold the hustle
and then this podcast hits number one on
the charts and more people hear about it
and then we do some viral thing and then
that goes viral you get more popular
there
now what but sean do you actually want
this yeah you actually
want yes people betting
i'll say something i like about it is
i've always kind of
tried to be an early adopter of certain
things right that i was excited and like
naturally curious about
and i would tell all my friends but i
had no way of like riding the wave with
the person i was popularizing
i would go i'd be like yeah you really
should check out this awesome musician
and then they would just get really
famous and like they would get way
richer
and in fact i often couldn't even talk
to them anymore because they became too
big a deal to even you know return my
calls
and like i would have liked to have been
like on the ride with them like
financially
sam i met you before you started the
hustle
right and i was like this guy's the [__]
this guy's you know totally switched on
he's a dynamic dude okay
if you could if i could have just bought
stuck in you and not
bet on like for example i had the
opportunity to invest in the hustle the
media company i was like well i don't
know if this is gonna be like
this humongous billion dollar company or
what i don't know if this fits my
profile or whatever
i don't know about media but i was but i
was believing in you
the whole time and if i could if i could
have just bought sam
and owned sam for 25 years that's
something i want to do
i think that you are going to become a
hitter and you're already on your way to
becoming a hitter
and if i could have done that from the
beginning or like you know we've talked
about the founders of calm
i was buddies with them early on now
calm is so big that i feel guilty even
hitting them up to go hang out with them
because i'm like ah they just
everybody wants their time they're busy
with their you know huge company
what am i gonna do i really wanna go
hang with them now so you know i'm a fan
from afar now
but at the time if you said that you
could buy alex too and you could buy
michael actin smith
you could buy their uh their their coins
i would i would bet in all my friends
coins right
i and i do with my time but i don't ever
get to benefit financially
from spotting future stars today
i uh that was a good speech i think that
i'm a little bit
uh on board now dude i feel the exact
same way there's so many entrepreneurs
including
uh the guys at com that i met through
summit early on
and for whatever reason i didn't persist
in getting didn't get the ability to
invest in their company
you know they it was mentioned i i
didn't i didn't like you know i missed
the email
a friend of mine heard about it i wasn't
at the right event when they were
raising i met him three months earlier
whatever
now i can actually bet on these people
it's it's i don't know well
this is why there's two there's two huge
problems is the fact that you've just
put
tens of thousand dollars on this website
and you get you can't get the damn thing
to [__] turn off
right now for this entire podcast this
podcast has been on for 45 minutes and
it's
it says big big clout is under brief
maintenance all
funds are safe thank you for your
support it's a black screen with a wrist
yeah like aerial 14 size font yes
it looks like a terrorists or kids right
now
i remember when facebook first came to
my college and i was like we were one of
the first
colleges and i remember like calling it
was really fun that this is the first
time i felt like that in a long time
that's why i wanted to come on the show
and talk about it but there's two major
differences which is you didn't have
money on facebook
and two you you knew a little bit about
the background and who made it
we're looking at this anonymous thing
that isn't working and you have money on
it that's a little nerve-wracking
and also you can't even get your money
back out if you want it by the way sam
do you know how many of my like angel
investments went to like i had no clue
someone was like you should try like
this guy
said from this person then you should
throw 50k in this thing
and i was like what the least i could do
could i do 10k okay cool here's 10k
and you know so over i think now 25 of
those or so have gone to zero
but a few of them pop so i'm looking at
this like an angel investment right like
i'm looking at this as like
one in ten but i get it i'll do it
i'll do it but i'm not gonna like i
think that people like youtube
need someone to criticize you because
like just everything on paper that we're
doing here
it's just like this sounds like a
horrible total scam
and i think you should be optimistic
about it and i'll definitely dabble in
it so
here's the other thing right like let's
let's say you said something earlier
like facebook didn't have money in it
like i think you met i think what you
meant was you didn't have to put in
tons of money to bed and facebook you
could just start using the thing and
it's kind of like you know
the risk like brian just said that that
his
uh normal young friends had a quarter of
their life saving
so okay so so here's the part that i
think is exciting and a lot of people
have talked about this this is the first
attempt
that it actually clicked with me and i'm
like oh this might actually work
so there's a whole bunch of people that
since crypto came out that were like oh
my god
we need to take the social networks and
we need to convert them into crypto
networks basically what we need is
why don't like why does facebook and
twitter and instagram why do they make
all the money and we do all the work
we make the content we like each other
we put our attention and our time into
viewing the content viewing the ads
and um advertisers spend all the money
and they don't you know they're hoping
to make a return on the other side
but the users who do all the work to on
these user-generated content platforms
reap only social value no financial
value
and so a whole bunch of attempts were
made people tried to make steemit which
was like reddit but like
instead of the karma being kind of funny
money it was like real money you know
type of thing but never took off
and uh but the fundamental always did
make sense which was
if you did get on a platform early and
you were one of the people that helped
make it big
why don't you ever get any reward for
that if you were one of the first uber
drivers first airbnb host first
power users on instagram you know like
what is it worth for those people that
are on clubhouse today
that are making content you know
freaking 24 7 and trying to make
clubhouse successful
and they're they're not the investor in
clubhouse it's you know andrews horowitz
and like
easy and kevin hart and [__] and so um
so it's easy he's not an investor but
well
because he's dead one thing i love about
this that you're saying is when i got
into some of these
you know awesome investments like uber i
couldn't share them with anybody i'd
call my mom and be like you really um
sorry but i i can't even get you i
couldn't get you in
you know and now it's like i feel
excited i wanted to come on the show and
like share it with the listeners
and like share it with trends because i
was like [__] everybody as soon as i get
this password and as soon as the site's
back up
like we can all actually we're like as
soon as the site works
and as soon as they open it and as soon
as withdrawals happen this is totally
gonna be sweet
but until those three primary
fundamentals work
this is garbage i say i was rightfully
pointing out the obvious
oh no it's very risky right now it's
very early days by the way we need to
talk about the investment strategy
because the next thing is once you get
on you become addicted and you're like
what is the strategy and i have like
five strategies oh yes
well can we talk about your friend who
can we he's talking about where are you
investing strategy by the way
i know i know but can we talk about this
because i think this is pretty
interesting
i won't name names but can i say details
of the story right i'm going to
so you had a friend who sold a business
and it was uh amongst like your everyday
person
massive home run um but
he the amount of money that he made was
not enough that you would go and do what
he did and he
hired two full-time people to invest his
money
yeah and we're talking like potentially
like digit millions of dollars which
again
is a lot of money but not enough to like
have two people on staff full-time to
invest your money
and that's what he did and ryan said
that it
ended up being a massive success even
though you thought it was a stupid
stupid idea
and it totally worked yeah i mean the
thing that blew my mind is
a friend of mine made a similar amount
of money to the money i made selling
my media company and i i did not think i
had nearly enough money to build what
you know is called like a family office
right like
i i need at most i'll hire a wealth
manager i'll pay them like a half a
point of the money under management
they'll invest my money in stock and
whatnot
and my friend instead hired two hedge
fund guys and analysts and like a full
like a real like associate vice
president like a senior guide
at like a hedge fund and is paying them
like you know i don't know like a half a
million
collectively in salary a year which is
like a very high percentage of
his money and and giving them as well
carried interest and upside
and i at the time this was in 2016. i
thought
that's the craziest thing i've ever
heard from the world's smallest family
office
and what what he now he what was smart
is he had a very good
like kind of similar to us he had he had
a good network
and he didn't have time to underwrite
all the deals that would come down
he didn't have time to run a financial
model or call people and dig you know
kick the tires and make sure that you
know the thing was real and that was a
good investment
but he had a lot of flow like we do and
so i don't have time to look at most of
my investments because i don't have an
analyst
and i don't have the time myself because
i put my own time into my business right
so i thought what was crazy is he did
that and he's up like a lot like i don't
know exactly
how much but like let's just say his his
big cloud investments are like 100 x
marks you know so
so you um what is the typical size of a
family office what amount of wealth does
an individual need to
where you oh you typically they'll be 50
million themselves 100 it's definitely
in like the i think at 50 you split it
with another family
so i i worked at jp morgan private bank
in college as an intern which at the
time was the largest
wealth management organization and and
they had billionaires as clients who did
not have family offices they hired jp
morgan to be their family office
but the really big clients at the firm
would somewhat someone someone that
would also
have a family or would leave the firm to
form it and so back then this is back in
like 2004
like i don't think you had a family
office unless you were like one of the
top 50 richest people in the world it
was my recollection of the time
and then there and then and then came
these ideas of multi-family offices
where people
share billionaires in our family office
and
now obviously things have become much
more like i think there's more and more
of this going on and so i think people
are forming family offices you maybe
have
i thought a couple hundred million 100
million but what was amazing about my
friend is that
you know this is somebody who had more
like low eight figures and
had essentially formed a family office
yeah i like the idea of the shared
family office by the way that makes a
lot of sense to me i'm surprised that
doesn't happen more
at like every level of wealth it does
you could
yeah there's like shared family off i
mean i think that like once you get into
like the 40 50 million range it makes
sense to like
do like three or four people together um
but
yeah for making
less than 20 which is still a
significant amount of money the idea of
hiring
a full-time staff is kind of outlandish
and that's kind of cool so i have a
similar
setup i'm lucky that like the business i
have
make enough income where you know it's
cool like this isn't it it's a business
expense it right it's basically
there's a lot of tax i would otherwise
be paying um and so
instead of paying tax i actually get
this individual to actually grow the
thing
and um and so that was my logic but that
might be sort of silly logic but it's
definitely more than what most people do
what do you think that it
is it's already working as far as i'm
concerned you know i think it's a
fair trade yeah by the way i i agree
more i mean investing in talent is just
always pays off if you're if you're like
willing to iterate and try and
experiment and you're you have hustle
and you work hard
in my experience so i love it i i i
hired a
a bookkeeping firm in europe and they've
created my books for my coaching
business for
you know renting my home for all of my
investments
and for my personal and then i have like
an executive assistant who you know
frees up a bunch of my time
and i've been thinking about hiring
somebody to just like manage my
investments
with me which is part of why i was
mentioning this to sam the other day
that my friend had this great success
you know doing this and i think it makes
all the more sense for you sean you know
because you're obviously you're
you're also operating labor-intensive
businesses like where you have to like
you know
create things put them online like
e-commerce and i mean
i just think it's like i think it's a
little nutty to do some of this because
if you just kind of let your money sit
like
it's gonna grow pretty good doing boring
ass [__]
and the question is is is doing all this
extra stuff actually gonna work out if
you do it for three decades
you know what what will you perform
better doing and sure sean you're
crushing it now or i i think i bet you
are
because bitcoin is growing and the
economy is booming but do you think that
over the next 30 years that what do you
think is going to be better for you um
you know i think it's true that most
people fail to just beat the passive
index when you account for fees that's
like
been proven out but also you know most
people is not all people so
i think there is you know maybe having
the network that we have in silicon
valley is actually significant enough of
an edge where this with this works for
me i didn't think about it like an
investor uh
i need somebody to do but manage my
money if it was just managed my money i
would not
i definitely wouldn't pay somebody in
house to do it for me it was like
cool i want to be you know creating
content i want to be running this angel
fund but i don't want to be taking all
these meetings and i don't want to be
you know like i'll be in a meeting you
know i'll be in a business meeting and
then my newsletter will go out
and people will like look at their phone
and be like how did you what is that
and i'm like oh yeah like i don't write
everything i don't send all this stuff i
don't do the formatting i don't do
all the research like i have somebody i
really trust and we work together on it
and i'm more the editor than the author
and um and that's like the case for a
lot of the different things i do
when i was raising the rolling fund i
didn't have time to go raise all the
money
i tweeted [__] out and then a bunch of
things came inbound and then my guy
basically like
took those inbounds and turned them into
cash in the bank and i was like this is
magic
um he does that every week he goes
through my dms and he's just like hey
he gives me an excel sheet that says
like for example for this clubhouse one
it was insane it was like
malcolm gladwell follows you now this
guy follows you now this guy follows you
now
i'm gonna here's some dms i have as like
something to say to them or they said
this i'm thinking about replying this
just say yes or no and i just say yes or
no and then he does all of it right and
it's like that is
being in two places at once i'm down to
pay for that i'm not really
personally i don't think it makes sense
for me to pay just for
investment advisor or sort of a wealth
manager from where i'm at
i'm less vulnerable
i think if you keep iterating on the
concept you'll find that it's actually
extremely lucrative
to hire even into this this role because
your rolling fund for instance imagine
if you had someone just full time
focusing on growing the the sean
investment world i do know because
sam so one thing i think you're missing
out on is that it's not just investing
your capital
it's the ability for you to raise
special purpose vehicles and syndicate
and so i did uh i did i did my first one
yesterday i raised a hundred fifty
thousand dollars
okay are you you can carry an interest
on that yeah
okay so imagine if you had someone full
time spinning up more of those so that
you were
getting 20 you know carried interest in
you know instead of one deal a month
what if you're doing 10 deals a month
but you would need you would need like
some infrastructure around that yeah
one of the coolest examples i think i
think doing it though for investing
is actually a little silly i mean
it's not silly it's just it's hard
because a lot of these angel investments
won't pay money for eight years
so what are you gonna like front the
bill early on so i actually think what
sean's doing is actually the right move
because
he if someone's working on other income
generating things earlier
like i think their investments
westminster you just need to structure
them differently
two and twenty so the two percent in a
in a hedge fund venture fund or private
equity fund pays
for your overhead it pays for your
investment sean are you doing two
percent
i took zero percent management fee uh
because i didn't know if anyone would
really want to invest in the rolling
fund so i was like okay
why do i how do i differentiate from the
other five people that are like me
they're like an entrepreneur who's had
an exit
has done some angel investing and just
spun up a rolling front because i was i
think in the first 10 rolling funds i
think i was one of the first 10 maybe
20.
and so i knew there's gonna be like 100
more of these in the next quarter
uh how do i like just quickly raise this
amount
and differentiate myself and i said well
i hate [__] fees i hate fees all the
time
so i was like i'm just gonna take no
fees i have enough income coming in from
other places that like i'll do this
and i have a i have two full-time people
that basically are not full-time i
shouldn't say that
i have two people that are dedicated one
is this guy romine who you've probably
seen on twitter he's
a real smart guy he he himself owns a
really successful big business
uh manny has a podcast and he's like an
investor himself
and i basically said he went to college
with me i said hey i need somebody to
kind of manage my fund
and take a bunch of these meetings
because i don't have a ton of time and
uh
do you want to do it like we're going to
invest in 25 30 companies a year
you know so like if you want that
experience while you're running your
company before you eventually sell your
company like
let's do this and he's like x harvard
mackenzie
uh you know he's a former lawyer like
he's a super sharp guy
and then i have this other guy who's a
scout that basically
he works at on deck and he went through
yc and he referred himself i think 20
companies into this yc batch
so he's like boots on the ground sees
everything before it even gets into yc
and so those guys basically are doing my
uh rolling funds
you know one guy does the scouting and
the other guy does the vetting and then
i basically am doing the
um the you know the final meetings with
the founders and making the final
decisions on a lot of those
and so that's been a pretty sweet way to
do this
investing and now we're doing four
million dollars a year of startup
investing
um you know that's up i was doing
probably i don't know
200 000 a year before that so you know i
was able to get
massive leverage by doing this and i
just agreed to split the carry with
these guys because i'm taking no
management fees i said
hey you get a piece of my carry instead
of me paying you a huge salary
right this is how normal funds start
they often start with little to no
management fees in order to incentivize
people to invest and then
as they mature and grow reputation they
start to charge management fees which is
which is by the way a service to the
investor because they don't want you to
be understaffed and under
under infrastructure like a really a
really extreme
where where this goes at the most
extreme when i worked at carlisle i was
pretty
a pretty fun example of this is david
rubinstein the the co-founder
and the lead fundraiser at carlisle had
a full-time equity analyst who would you
know graduate from like yale or
princeton
who worked at merrill lynch who he would
hire and he would go through these i
think every few years
all they would do all day is do research
so that when he would speak on a podcast
he would sound extremely intelligent
because he knew
everything that he needed to know about
what's happening in china or dubai
or whatever the whatever the topic of
the day was because he had a team of
people like you know you had a small
little like crew working on this who
were actually trained equity research
analysts
so you can imagine all the things you
could invest in like people who make you
know make sure that your research for
your podcast for example
which that i know sean has that and we
have that uh or we're getting a lot more
of that
here all these investments are going to
make your big cloud go up
tying you back so ryan let's let's
finish up the big club thing so
you have put in uh tens of thousands of
dollars into big cloud i believe
and you are what is the strat
you're using right now you're looking
for undervalued basically like sam you
said
okay sean and sam about similar twitter
followings but sean's coin is more
expensive right now so i'm gonna buy a
ton of sam
and also they're in the same vehicle of
my first million so like
you know you know there's a good chance
they'll they'll grow together so you saw
sam as an undervalued asset
is that the core thing you're doing
basically just looking for the
undervalued
so so there's two main investment
strategies and then there's multiple
investment strategies under the second
one so the first one is you just buy big
cloud and you just bet on the whole
platform
and i'm probably going to keep like 60
of my money just in big cloud
and then once you own big clout you can
buy and buy creator coins right
creator coins are like the sam coin the
sean coin
within that strategy i have a few
strategies so one is
i buy undervalued people like the sampar
who until yesterday was valued at zero
and i and i bet that he's gonna go up
right
and then there's people i've also bought
some elon musk and some chamath and some
of the people who are already trading at
really high numbers
because i just think it's the plot
they're blue chippers popular people are
going to go to the
to the face the fang of bitcoin
basically right
that's like buying like you know it's
like buying like yeah like walmart
you know i was buying like you know
champagne or naval um
so and then i'm looking like i'm telling
you chuck norris you watch chuck norris
is gonna
go up like
austin reef at morning brew i think he's
gonna go way up
and he's gonna do better than sam
because sam's kind of being a wuss about
big clown from what i can tell
i i think it's true i am being a little
bit of a wuss i just can't tell if i'm
just
like so sam did you ever see
old-fashioned did you see this thing
that came out a couple years ago
um by sikki chen called famous or it was
also called stolen because there was two
there's two versions of it was called
stolen initially and then
uh that was a little bit too
controversial and they ended up having
to change the name to famous
and then even that can't do
controversial they just had the whole
app got taken down
it was extremely viral so what what
stolen and famous were
was basically people started tweeting
out one day
just stole at seanvp just stole at
the sam far
[Music]
and the stolen account had like the
funniest buy i don't remember what it
was but it was just like you know
it wasn't trying to explain what it was
it was like just like
um super low key about the whole thing
and so what it was was you could just go
and
if you place the top bid it was like you
uh you have the hot potato like you
owned that person because you made the
winning bid and so it was an auction of
people
on twitter and so you could go and you
could buy and have all you could buy
ryan hoover you could buy all these
people
for some amount of money and then that
would be like the winning bid somebody
had to top you in order to take it
and um and so it went super viral super
quickly
in the kind of like product tech silicon
valley bubble
and then i guess they didn't like the
connotation of stolen so then they
rebranded as famous af
and so famous af started working and
then it went so viral that it was going
into schools
and like bullying was happening because
people were just stealing like
classmates and then like dumping them or
something like that i don't know what it
was but like
some teacher came out and was like or
some mom came out was like dude my kid
is getting bullied via stolen
via via famous and this is like messed
up and then
apple took it off the app store because
they were like what is this bullying app
and so um and so that was the and so so
sikhi who's the
guy behind it he made sandbox vr and
he's you know doing runway
uh yeah yeah yeah cool new startup and
so this guy's this guy's a gangster and
so he he built these games and so now
every time i see big clout
and by the way anytime anybody sees big
cloud that no seeky they're like oh this
is it he's like dude i know like just
stop saying to me like
uh please to stop sending me if one more
[__] person sends me a big clout link
you know i'm gonna lose my mind and uh
so this has happened before and it did
go viral before
i think there's a very good chance that
this goes viral again it has two
kind of core things going against it
one is um it's
it looks a little bit shady and it's
come across a little bit shady so far
um and you have to have a password to
get in so which is
which is one of the reasons the friction
of the password is one
one major friction right that's why it's
not going viral right now
it's going viral within a small circle
but not like super viral
because it's not open to everybody yet
and then the second thing
is you have to you have to transfer in
bitcoin in order to use it
and so that already limits it right
there's like just very few people who
even own bitcoin
so you know that's a big big gate in the
way of this thing going crazy
but everything else i think is it is
engineered it is pro
from a product design perspective this
is designed
brilliantly and this will grow in the
way that it's designed
well what uh spent the better part of
yesterday trying to teach my mom and my
sister how to create coinbase accounts
transfer answer bit buy bitcoin transfer
bitcoin
uh sean do you think that angel
investing like is this going to be
what's the future of sean pray i mean
do you think that this is going to be
your full-time job angel investing
is a way to for me it's like just
dipping a net into a stream of flowing
water with a bunch of fish inside i'm
not
taking a boat out spending you know an
afternoon
out in the water fishing and trying to
catch something is this
in front of my house there's this stream
with fish going through and if i just
put a net in
i can catch some great fish that's what
angel investing is for me and that's
what it's been basically for the last i
don't know six seven years where
my own friends my own personal network
or things that come inbound through
getting more popular on twitter and the
podcast
it leads you to some opportunities
people want you in their deals and you
get to see deals early
and before i used to sit on the sideline
i watched a bunch of those companies get
big
and then i started you know i asked a
rich friend hey
if i give you a good deal that you
invest in can i get a piece of the carry
i said yeah that's how i got into lambda
school which is already kind of like a
big winner
and then as soon as i did that i was
like man instead of a big like instead
of getting a piece of this guy's carry
why can't i just do this myself
so as i got a little more money i
started doing it myself and then with
the rolling fund that just lets me do it
on steroids where i can just do more
and so what percentage of your net worth
well could let's be you can not answer
this but let's just say that you invest
four million dollars a year in eight
years
how much income do you think you're
going to do you think you're going to
make an additional 200
do you think you're going to make 200
grand a year do you think you're going
to make sure
a a good fund is going to like
let's say 3x it's money over the kind of
like seven to 10 year period
uh great will be you know 5x or more
and like if you're if you count if you
caught an uber if you caught a coin base
uh you know you're laughing your your
returns are going to be super skewed
just by this one
company that's now worth tens of
billions but let's assume for this
conversation
let's assume you're only so let's say
you're the first um let's take let's
take three x let's take the most cons
like the most conservative version of
winning right is i triple the money
so over the next three years i'm going
to deploy 12 million dollars
let's say i 3x that money that's 36
million dollars
um that gets that comes back into the
fund after returning the money so
uh so a total of 148 million dollars
and so on the 36 that's the profit
i get to keep twenty percent of the
carry right so that's about seven
million dollars-ish
is my mental math right um you know
roughly seven
roughly seven million dollars and that's
seven million dollars over a
let's call it eight eight to ten year
time span it's not the biggest like
that's
that's why i don't go all in on it is
because i can make way more money
building a business in that same amount
of time so if i
well in seven so but that's as a recap
that's you're you're my did you how much
in sev you say seven million years yeah
that's a significant amount of money
that's a million dollars a year so
you're thinking this will make you a
million dollars a year for seven years
starting in seven years no i think it's
like kind of like a lump sum
that you get in seven years more more
like it i get nothing for
for seven years and then as these
companies as the
as many of them die and some of them do
okay then a few winners
emerge and eventually you reach a steady
state where you keep going and you are
making
a millionaire yeah really what's
interesting is where you scale
and you start doing you know 20 million
50 million a year 100 million a year
uh and you know eventually that's why
you could see yourself hiring investment
professionals you could have a whole
fund
haven't has any years paid out ryan yeah
yeah but i i i think there's another
important point is it's not just about
money it's about well-being
as i'm always saying on the show like
it's about
like what investing has done for me is
it's been a vehicle for learning and for
connecting to really interesting people
and for like getting to like kind of
like go on these fun adventures where
i'm like learning about like the latest
things in crypto or
the latest things in e-commerce and i'm
connecting dots and then the other thing
it's done is it's made my
my primary businesses far more
successful
because i'm borrowing ideas i'm learning
like oh wow look how this e-commerce
company does performance marketing i've
never even heard of performance
marketing until
and then i brought it back to a
newsletter company and like oh at our
newsletter company
we can buy facebook ads and google ads
like this ecom company that i invested
in called warby parker or whatever
and like i'm now i'm like cross you know
i'm taking you know i mean kind of like
what your show has done a really nice
job of your but does it no
does it distract you from your main job
well that's that's where like
that's why i think it was smart that
this guy hired some people and how you
know sean's hiring some people because
then then you can kind of like be as you
said in two places at once
but no that's you just have to you just
have to take the risk of hiring a
hundred and fifty thousand two hundred
thousand dollars well you're not you
don't have to
i mean i i haven't done that and i've
still made a bunch of investments but
but i missed a lot of investments
because of that very reason because i
was like
hey i'm really laser focused on biz now
and summit and powder mountain i'm not
going to
look at a deal every day i'm going to
look at like a deal every like three
weeks
and so i'm just going to miss a lot of
stuff you know i missed like
i mean i i have a one of my the ceo of
my company invested 150 grand in a um
in a in a crypto hedge fund and he's you
know he's up to like
almost six million dollars of value i
don't know if i should be saying that
here but
you know he i missed that because i was
just like i'm busy i can't look at that
right now yeah that's totally true and
by the way most of the time when people
say like
oh it's not about the money it's about
the journey it's about the
learning it's about the people you meet
you know the kumbaya thing
normally that's like you know that's the
tell it's actually almost always about
the money
because if you took the money out they
wouldn't do any of the [__] this is
actually one of the rare things where
that's actually true
because i actually was doing all these
things i was meeting founders i was
helping them with their businesses
i was getting excited and digging into
new spaces i was keeping a fantasy
portfolio of like
to learn like oh i'm tracking these
spaces and i think these are going to be
big and i want to learn about these
spaces and
here's some of the companies that are
doing cool things and let me observe
their growth tactics from the outside
and try to see what's working
and maybe apply that to my business i
was literally doing all those things for
fun
before i ever put a dollar in uh you
know i was subscribed to like
i don't know 50 different um angel list
syndicates because you didn't have to
put money in but you could get the
investment memo
because i literally loved the learning
so much and i had no plan at the time to
be investing in any of those i put zero
dollars in
sorry to all those syndicate leads you
know i was that annoying guy that was
subscribed and never invested
but it was because i actually genuinely
actually wanted to learn and i wanted to
meet these founders
and so this is one of the rare occasions
where when you hear that
normally it's [__] in this case i'm
a hundred percent on board with which
everyone and like
that's how i that's exactly how i think
about it is this is like a
my other friend described it as like it
it's a great way to just blow off some
entrepreneurial steam
it's like you your brain if you're
operating a business you all of a sudden
start hearing about vertical farming and
crypto and then like you know oh what
the hell is you know what the hell are
nfts and like you learn about all this
[__] and then
part of you is like should i be doing
that like what the [__] am i doing this
stupid like
real estate newsletter i should be going
out there building you know this ride
sharing company or whatever
and so investing gives you a way to like
get the high and dabble in that and have
some financial upside
but you don't it lets you stay focused
as an entrepreneur so that's the other
like
like weird psychological things that
comes from investing is
um aside from the learning aside from
the good friends you make and the
network you build and the learn you know
the cross ideas you get you literally
just get to like it's like a release
and uh and then you can go back to doing
your thing do you
but but are you sean are you the reason
i i did the syndicate thing
i'm doing it with joe and where i i bet
my own money it's it's kind of like a
rolling fine but it's not
uh it's only deal by deal basis where
sean you have like money
that you could deploy a little more
freely i didn't do the rolling fun thing
because i didn't want to have customers
that i have to
uh appease and talk to on a regular
basis because i didn't want like a job
do you feel know now that you have like
a job because you have a hundred people
who have given you yeah
no i write a once a month update uh and
i like doing it anyways it's just hey
here's the new companies we
invest in why i would do that for my own
documentation anyways of
what was the conviction at the time i
made the investment here's what i
believe here's why i believe investing
in it
i like having that anyways for five
years from now that's an important thing
for me
so in this case i just publish it to my
investors great
so that's the that's all the maintenance
that goes into it there was a little bit
again early on of like actually getting
the investors on board but i took no
meetings
i took no phone calls i just said here's
the link and because of this podcast
because of
my newsletter because of my own track
record and the deck i made
that was enough to raise the money for
me and i know that that's kind of like a
not everybody can do that part most
people would have to go knock on a bunch
of doors and really sell this thing
um so that's that but the other thing
you mentioned like for you
if you just get busy and you just don't
care about angel investing you could
just not do a deal for the next six
months and no sweat
whereas for me i actually do need to
deploy this money and so there is like
a certain amount of like startup pitches
i need to take every month
in order to be doing great investments
um
and so you know i actually have to
deploy this money i can't like
just sit on my hands and decide i want
to go go on vacation or like just go
super heads down in my own business i
can't like
i can't do that because i've taken on a
fiduciary like obligation
to deploy these people's cash right what
i thought would be man
i used to invest i don't know like 50k a
quarter 100k a quarter max
and now i have to deploy a million
dollars a quarter
and actually i run out within the first
two months of every quarter so so it's
actually not been an issue
because i just my check sizes are bigger
and once people know you're investing
they send you deals your friends send
you deals
they're like hey i'm doing this this is
a good deal and they're like oh wow i
didn't need to
like the fundamentals make sense and all
is all the good there's other good go
co-investors there
i didn't need to go find this deal it
came to me uh and that's
that's the best thing that happens what
percentage of what percentage of your
liquid net worth
did you allocate to before this because
now with the rolling fund i'm investing
rpm right other people's money i only
put
a small amount of my own money for the
fund before this
i was doing roughly 200k 250k a year
was what i put in and i don't remember
what that was at that time of like
liquid net worth it was like kind of
substantial like it was it wasn't
wasn't i don't know half a percent or
something it was like
like that mattered to me but also if i
lost that money or if
like i knew going in at the very least
this money is locked up for a long time
i can't use it to go
buy a vacation over or under 15 over
under 15 or 10 percent
like was it more than like 10 because
that's a lot i don't know
i don't have to think what i i don't
know how much money i made at the time
because i made more money in the last
couple years than i did
back then so i don't know actually how
much money i had then what i do remember
is thinking
when i very first started i thought i
need about 300 000
of a bankroll to even do this to have
enough of a portfolio to give myself a
shot
because angel investing so many of your
deals are going to be losers
and so i thought okay i need to have you
know 20 to 30 bets i need at least 300
to 500 000
of bankroll to go do this and at that at
the very beginning i didn't have that
that would have been an irresponsible
amount of money for me that was like at
the time
i don't know half of the money i had or
something like that so i said okay i
can't do that
that's why i started talking to other
people and being like hey if i scout for
you can i get carrie
and you put up the capital and that's
how i got started
although you know operate go ahead even
when you have almost no money i i really
like this as opposed to buying public
equities
when you have very little money because
of the learning and the connections and
like the benefit that that could have on
your own business
like i was betting a very high
percentage of my money initially
and it really helped me because i rather
than just buying like coca-cola
or walmart or some publicly traded
company where i learn
nothing i meet no one you know i it
doesn't really help like the day-to-day
of my like newsletter business or my
community business or you know the the
real estate business if these things
were basically benefiting
my ability to make money on my day job
so that's why i i actually
think when you're small it's actually
not a terrible idea and in fact
a high point i've read a tim ferriss
thing a while back
he wrote a long time ago before before
he started investing and he was
basically like i'm just going to fund my
own mba
like if i was going to spend 200k yeah
business school i think i can learn
more investing that 200k in a mix of you
know
public stocks and private you know
startups and when i read that i was like
oh absolutely like
i will build a network i will build
business knowledge i'll have skin in the
game and actually
this might become a profitable thing you
know but the worst case scenario this
was my rather than going to you know
wichita state and like going get my mba
like why would i not do this so once i
read that
that's how i started thinking about it
was like i'm going to put 120k in
that's like a you know that's business
school and let me let me just get going
well so we we not only thought about
that with investing but we
we lost 25 000 on the first summit we
held various
private summits in between summits where
we would lose 20 grand here 10 grand
there to throw like an event
and i always saw that as an investment
like you're saying like in like my
network or my learning
and the same thing i was talking to a
guy the other day about he wanted some
coaching
and he was like debating whether i was
worth like the monthly amount and he had
like 400 grand
in his savings and i was like well what
do you want to do what else do you want
to do with the 400 grand
he wanted to put it into like robin hood
and buy stock and i was thinking like
man if i had known about
coaching or consulting or some of the
things i now know about
you know like trainings that you could
go get online
you're taking like a writing course from
like you know parel online
like those things are so valuable like
they're so worth the like three grand
here the five grand there that
if you have you know a little bit of
money saved
i think that's so much better than
trying to make like you know the index
return on the stock market
when at least when you don't have that
much money i i think um
somebody said to me you know concentrate
to get rich diversify to stay rich like
when you don't have much money like put
your money into building yourself up
building up your learning building up
your network
and then later when you're when you're
much richer then diversify and
have a you know an allocation and a
portfolio like that
i don't know if we're gonna get so like
sean do you agree
i think the clips that we're doing are
like the greatest thing that's like one
of the most proud things i am of my
career even though they're all of you
it's like it's the most proud thing that
like i'm
so proud of that and i'll we i don't
even know if anyone has made it this far
but we're gonna
we uh we hired i can tell you we hired
these we were
just about done with the contract
they're gonna be doing 30 to 60 a month
across the whole hustle organization and
you and i can take up as many as we want
um i think that they are the greatest
thing ever and all i want to do
is talk in talking 120 second
bytes so it becomes uh ryan you got to
google google the hustle on instagram
and you'll see these clips i'm talking
about
they're getting like sean sean did one
the other day that uh the michael jordan
thing i think it has 150 000 views at
this point
um me and zach did one where that has 80
000 views
like it's so fun it's the most proud i
am so i don't know if we're gonna get
any clips out of this i feel like
if if the guys by the way the guys who
are listening to this and
doing it if you don't feel like you get
a great big clout clip from this
message me on slack i'm gonna record a
clip worthy bitcloud thing because i
know how you guys will animate it
because we have to get a bit cop clip
that has to happen
you through either the stuff you got out
of this wait or i will say a full
like two-minute monologue i wanna i
wanna do a clip too let's all do it
let's all get them let's go
they're they're really good you chad's
not sean's naturally good at it i think
i'm
okay at it uh ryan you gotta talk way
faster to get good at it you gotta like
you have to pack these with information
and you have to talk really fast
that's kind of hard that's good i have
to jump because i have uh a i'm getting
back to baby that b i have a very
i'm gonna literally go execute a shake
down uh
right now and i can't wait to see what
happens if i get shot
you know hey this was my last hurrah by
my big clout in my memory
but uh i got to go shake down somebody
who stole something from me
and uh get it back because uh i know who
hasn't
god i love you i remember you you were
talking about this one said you were
like dude i would go back and
you said you have done it or you said
you would go do it
i have done it and i'll remember to help
myself at the time being like
this guy's a maniac i would never do
that and now i'm so enraged that the
person stole
and also like there's no other recourse
the cops are like well you know what are
we gonna do
like you're the [__] cops and like
you know the
you know the lawyers like well you could
try to like sue him but you know
just don't cross the line [__] him like
don't hurt
don't don't physically hurt him just
just yeah
the cops were like here's what okay
they're like once they understood what i
wanted they're like oh
you need something called a civil assist
and a civilization where cop goes with
you you say i'm going to confront
somebody and a cop goes with you
to ensure that nothing goes down just as
a thought so to let it go
and think of it as oh my god you know
right let it be
angry i understand don't tell them to
forget about this person will keep
stealing unless they
understand that we know that they're
stealing and we can stop them from doing
it so uh
me just well you can you could say to
them i i hey
by the way i know you're stealing and
i'd really appreciate it if you don't
steal
enjoy the things you've already stolen
no and uh
i'd really appreciate if you would like
anymore all right
do you realize how house how much
rage drives people to be successful and
how much we're events i don't want you
to tell me to forget about it i want you
to teach me how to
use my rage to fuel me to be better dude
there's such funny things you can do
with this someone's been stealing my
bike seat outside my house here
i've been it's been stolen twice in the
last six weeks and like
you know you could just put a note
outside like here's i'm gonna put i'm
gonna go buy a few extra bike seats and
just leave them out for them
i think you put a nice dude note out
there with some lemonade
no taste them what the holes
no don't write them a note i want you to
like tase them
all right come on come to miami oh
you're going to tease him i'm gonna give
him lemonade and we'll let's let's see
how it all plays out man now i'm torn
i'd rather your shoulder telling me to
you know turn the other side
and go today
go to amazon type in paddle prod
order the top one meditation cushion
yeah that's right you do your way i'll
do my one guys
yeah i feel like i can rule the world i
know i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back